ED BETWEENCA
GREEN CALLEDES
GREEN.
KEVIN McCARTHY CALLED THEM BOTH
INIR OFFICE AND SAID STOP
ITUTY DN.'S GREEN TELLI SON SHE
OUTH
S NOT ABPUVEE
NOW ITCTIONS
TH
O PUT AMERIC
POESTHEY'RE ELECTED TOE'S STILL
>> THELAE SEEN IISEEIF YSPEAKERD
MAR YOU TOGOVERN
WE'RE GOFINE.
>> QUITE
EVERNG
TALK ABOUT THIS.
HE HAD A CLOSED-DOOREETING TH H,
WTSO FOCUS ONUE ATHA WINNIS
BULHE HAS A HUGE PROBLEM BREWING
IF THE DEMOCRATS TAKE OVER THE
HAG BASIC
TRYING TO FUND THE GOVERNMENT,
CUY DEALS WITH DEMOCRATSN
THINGSIKE E  IT IS
CONSTANTLY IN THE NEWS HE S
MBERS OF HIS CONFEE CRATS WITH,,
CONSTANTLY.
THEN HE HAIKE MA GREENE AN
EACH OTHER'RE FITIH
OFFICE. BOTHS
O T SEEM TO HAVE
CONTRO R EVERYT
GREENE FORR
OWN TW AND RUN TO FI A TATTLE
>>HAAIE ME O
TALKED TO DONALD TRUMP ABOUT
WHAT WAS HER T
GOINTOPORT A P
CHAIPROBLEM FOKE
FT
TRUMP-SUPPORTED CONG
HOUSE VERY CLOSE TDO
TRUMP, HE CAN ENJOINWRATH.
>> WELCOO NDOW OF THE TY.
THIS I EXAMPLE O
INSIDE YOUR PAOUENT TCAUSES PRO
PAULU HAVE TO
GOVERN OR LEAD.
YOU GUYS HAVE DONEPOS NOT JFRJRT
NORM BDITIONAL
CONSVANSID CONFERENCE THAT HATTS
LITERALLY THE DUMBEST WEEK O
OU AND THAT IS A VERY,
VERYIF McCARY CAN'T E DIE FOEAN
HAS A PROBLEM WHEN HE BECOME
SP
, HI
IU DON'T HEARANY
TRYING
TO WEIGH I STEER TIR
WHT
ELEMENTS ANYREE ORE
MAINSTAM ELEMENTS OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTYTO ME  STORYE IS
YOU MENTIONED TAYLOR GREENHA  D.
WHAT DOES THATEAS REVENGE AND
RETRIBUTE E INS  F
STOLEN.WAS
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE AND ALL
WELL.PE THAT A
SO THEY WANT TO SEE McCARTHY,
SPEAKERSHIP AND THEY
JORITY, TH WASN'T TO
SEE HIM TAKE ACTION ON THIS.
LS O THIS ISS SCOTT PERRY, CONG
M T PERR -- ULAIS FOR THE
CI TARY 6th INSURRECTION BECAUSE
RESULTS, TRYINRUIT THEM
AND WAS A PART OF A LO AT
>> ANDOU'RE REW SPEAKINGERATES
HERE'S FRO,
DON BACON.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID TO MST
WE SHOULD NOT BSHOOTING
GHTING.OWI
NG TO SHOW W TO
AND THAT RUIS  PAR
PEOPLE'S CGHT NOW ALL OF THES
GREAFO BUTS UNDERMINEST OFBA GA
>> WHOT TH POINT.
THERE'S A LOT OFD TO THE MERONH
VERY LEAE TON THATHERA AN LLE TE
EN, HOW PRESIDENT IS, ETTERA.
D REPUBLICANS  NOT TO BE IN THI
THR AUDITION
ARAN
POWEROT TO GIVE CREDIT, SHE'BEH
OV HIM AND
UMANTANDS FOR INS USING EC
NT McCARTHY E HIS
IS SA
ERYONE AND THAT'S TOUGTOTO
F HIGHIN WILL,
THATE  AP
TO. WANT HIM E
SPEAKER IF HE CAN'
THES?D THEN IF HE'SE TO B
BEE ANSWER T OF THOSE ARE
UPN
D ISIGGE, EA
OVER REPUBLICAUSE ER THE YEARS O
LOOK AT THIS FROM 2006.
TOP DECRATS INLORELO, R,RN
AL
BL LEADERS, FROM
SCDA H
TH TO LEEFANIK, O CAME INTO  TSC
DAYHTING THINGS
WITH DONALD TRUMP OVER WT
THRE ALWAYS HAT'S SPN.
BEEN A PARTY IN THESENTAS AND S
CONFERENCE.
YOU HAVE A LTHE DIRECT
CONSTA.
INTHE STOF
BOEHNER AND HO DEALT WITH CA
YOU THINK OF THETY DEA.
McCA'S DEALING WE RIGHT FLANK,
CAUCUS, ANDWHAT YOUEE THEVERY D
FERENT NTS WHERE MEMBERS WANTED.
COULD THAT CHANGE